-My next guest is
a successful businesswoman,
a best-selling author,
and her new show
"Cooking with Paris"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Everyone, please welcome
Paris Hilton!
♪ -Paaaris Hilton ♪
♪ Serving up some news ♪
♪ You're probably thinking ♪
♪ I wonder how she cooks ♪
♪ So pay attention ♪
♪ Might learn something
todaaaay ♪
-Thank you so much.
Welcome back to our show.
Thanks for coming on.
-It's great to be here.
-There's lots to talk about.
I know that you just --
you got engaged.
-Yes.
-Are you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
Are you in the planning stages
now?
-Yes, we are planning
everything.
It's very stressful.
-It's a lot of stuff.
Have you picked out a dress?
-Yes, that's basically
the only thing that I've done.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's a lot of stuff, though.
-It's a lot. It's --
But I'm not a Bridezilla at all.
-No, I didn't think
you would be, though.
I think that you would have this
under control.
But here's the one thing I
thought was actually brilliant.
You're documenting your wedding
for a show, a series on Peacock.
-Yes.
-Why add that extra pressure?
-I just feel like for
my documentary, "This Is Paris,"
it ended in a way in which,
you know, it was an amazing --
but I just feel like
I wanted my fans to see
that I found my Prince Charming
and my happy fairy-tale ending.
-Yeah. Yeah, good, I'm glad.
[ Applause ]
Are you going to --
I know you -- You deejay.
You're one of the most famous
deejays out there.
Are you going to deejay at
your own wedding or get a band?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
I'll definitely get a deejay
because it's too much.
We'll have a band as well.
It's gonna be like
a three-day affair.
-Oh, really?
-We have a lot happening.
-Three days? Big deal.
-Yes.
-So more than one dress?
-Lots of dresses. Probably 10.
I love outfit changes.
-Yes. 10 outfits?
And how about
your husband-to-be?
Will he have outfit changes?
-He's not as high maintenance
as I am.
[ Laughter ]
-When you deejay, do you get
upset when people come up
to the booth and make requests?
-It depends on the request.
If it's like a brutal song,
yeah, that's annoying.
But if they have a good idea,
why not?
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-How's your mom and dad doing?
-They're doing amazing.
-Your mom's a hit, by the way.
She's on --
She's not a housewife
but she's on "Real Housewives."
And every time she's a hit.
-She's so funny.
-Did you -- Did she ask you
before she went on?
Like, "Hey, do you mind
if I do this?"
-We read about it on TMZ.
My sister and I were,
like, terrified because
we didn't want her getting
involved in all the drama.
But I'm very proud of her.
She's just herself. She's funny.
And people are loving it.
So I'm really proud of her.
-There was one that I saw
where, I think,
she didn't know what a Red Bull
was or something
or she didn't know
it kept you awake.
And she ended up drinking it
and staying up all night.
She couldn't go to sleep.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-How is "This Is Paris" going,
your podcast?
-It's so much fun. I love --
You know, I've been interviewed
like a billion times,
so to be the one doing it
and asking all the questions
is super fun.
-I find the show interesting
because you are so interesting.
You have so many things
going on.
When you ask a question
and someone will get --
some story will get brought up,
and you're like "Oh, yeah,"
and then you'll tell this story
like --
I didn't know how into NFTs
you were.
Do you guys know what that is?
-No.
-Yeah.
Like 12 people know what it is.
[ Laughter ]
I barely know.
Can you explain what an NFT is?
-It's a nonfungible token.
-Nonfungible.
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Which is basically
a digital contract
that's on the blockchain.
So you can basically have --
sell anything from art to music
to experiences,
physical objects.
-I'm not going to jump into
the NFT world, but I would --
I know Beeple is an artist
that's awesome.
-Yeah, so awesome.
-And he had maybe like 300
pictures in one digital picture.
I thought that was interesting.
And I go, "Well, I could never
do that, what he did."
-Yeah.
You could try something maybe.
Like sell one of your jokes
or something.
[ Laughter ]
-I couldn't even do that
to my audience tonight.
Are you kidding me?
[ Laughter ]
I doubt I would make money off
the NFTs.
I want to talk about
"Cooking with Paris" because --
you know,
with all these projects,
I get to know you more and more.
"This Is Paris,"
when you made that, I go, "Wow."
That was so interesting to see
that side of you,
and it just was very --
I loved it.
And this, the one I saw,
the episode is
you and Kim Kardashian.
How long have you known
each other, you and Kim?
-Since we were little girls,
our whole life.
-Yeah. And how many times
have you cooked together?
-Back in the day when we would
go out at night, like,
we'd come home late, and, like,
make grilled cheeses or --
-Really? What's your secret
to grilled cheese?
-Brioche bread, cheddar cheese,
lots of butter.
-Mmm.
I go Wonder Bread, American
Kraft singles, and yeah.
I could also do --
Yeah, lots of butter, yeah.
And make sure the pan is hot.
-Yes.
-Yeah, I do love
a grilled cheese. Gosh.
I want to show everyone a clip
from the show.
Here are Paris Hilton
and Kim Kardashian
on "Cooking with Paris."
Take a look at this.
-This is how it used to be.
Paris would have the ideas,
and I'd come in and be like,
"This is never going to
work out.
Like, this is not practical."
-You're the organized one.
I'm like the most disorganized
person in the world.
♪♪
This might work.
-We got --
[ Chuckles ]
-Oh, that's cute.
Killing it.
If this was cookies,
it would work, right?
-I'm going to need to,
like, touch up my makeup.
I'm literally crying.
The fact that you thought
these marshmallows could work.
Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
Wait, do I have blue
all over my face?
-[ Laughs ]
Paris Hilton, everybody.
"Cooking with Paris"
is streaming now on Netflix.